[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: More or less
annual event in the Department
of Aeronautics and
Astronomics, which
was made possible
by the [INAUDIBLE]
Major Lester Gardner.
It's an annual lecture
on history of aerospace.
Gardner was a graduate of the
class of '98, which we now
have to distinguish
by saying 1898,
as the Institute has now cycled
through more than a century.
And as best I can figure
out, he was basically
a buddy of [? Hunziker's. ?]
Is that right?
Does anyone remember
this far back?
[? Hunziker ?] seemed to
have this network of buddies
who were, A, influential,
and B, had money.
That's the image
that comes across.
And Gardner was one of them.
He published magazine
for a number of years
called Aviation and
Aeronautical Engineer.
And he was a decorated aviation
officer in World War I,
and gave us the fund that
allows the annual sponsorship
of this lecture, which is a
prestigious list of lectures.
I'll just read a few off
of the previous lectures.
Sikorsky, Doolittle, Sperry,
Otto Koppen, the two tailors,
[? Abe Silverstein, ?]
[? Doc Draper, ?] Hans
[INAUDIBLE],, Bill Sears,
Gerhard Neumann, T. Wilson,
Neil Armstrong, and Bob Seamans,
and most recently, René Miller.
And we're indeed
honored today to have
one of our alumnus, Joe Gavin.
Not only alumnus, a
very active supporter
in [INAUDIBLE] department.
Joe received his SB in 1841.
A member of the
famous class of '41
that included Jimmy [? Marr ?]
and a few other people who were
quite active in the department.
Who else was in
the class of '41?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLES]
MODERATOR: It's a long time ago.
AUDIENCE: Long time ago.
MODERATOR: About 55 years ago.
He was in the Naval
Reserve and served
in the Bureau of Aeronautics
during World War II.
He was a project officer for
the Navy's first jet fighter.
He joined Grumman after the
war as a design engineer,
and he served in many
capacities there,
including the one in which he
will talk about [? us ?] today.
That is, he was a vice
president and director
of the Lunar Module Program
during the Apollo era.
Served there until his
retirement in 1985.
Outside of Grumman, he's
had a lot of influence
on the nation and the world.
He's a member of the
AIAA since 1946, which
was before it was the AIAA.
In 1982, he was the president
of our professional society,
and became the honorary
fellow [INAUDIBLE]
[? honorary ?] fellow in 1984.
He's received a NASA
Distinguished Public Service
Medal, and was a member
of the National Academy.
He's a member of the
International Academy
of Astronautics, and he
was a director of the AAAS,
and became a fellow
of that in 1991.
And in his spare time, he's been
active here at the Institute
as a member of the
Educational Council.
Was the president of
the Alumni Association.
Has served on a number
of visiting committees,
including ours.
Is a life member
of the Corporation,
and has served on its
executive committee, which
is the seat of real power
in MIT, from 1984 to 1991.
So I would like to--
I would have the honor,
in fact, to introduce
Joe to give his address
on the technology
and programmatic development
of the lunar module.
GAVIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it's a very
considerable honor
to join the group who
have given this lecture.
It also brings back a rather
strong pang of nostalgia.
Now, I have to explain that it's
a little hard to feel nostalgic
about 10 years of
sheer desperation,
because that's
about what it was.
And I'm just going to hit
some of the high points here,
and I'll skip some of
the real difficult times.
But this program, the Apollo
program, started as a result,
I think, of the competition
in the Cold War.
There were many things
that led up to it,
and I would suggest that
the beginnings of NASA
and the beginnings of Apollo
are worth reading up on,
because they're
quite complicated.
In my view, one or
two major things.
Mr. Eisenhower
decided that NASA was
going to be an open,
unclassified agency.
He managed to fend off the
Air Force, who wanted the job.
And then, of course, Mr. Kennedy
made the commitment to do it.
And at the time that he
made that commitment,
one of his advisors
was saying that,
with the reliability
available [? and ?]
components at that time, that
it would take probably 40
landings--
40 attempts to make
a successful landing.
Well, it turned out
otherwise, of course.
And the credit really has to
go to an awful lot of people.
I'm here today to tell you, as I
remember it, about the program.
But there are an
awful lot of people
who were involved at Grumman
and at subcontractors
at the various NASA centers.
And it's pretty hard to
find any group, I think,
that worked as diligently
and in as focused
a fashion for those 10 years.
Well, now let's get
into the slides.
This particular slide is
from Apollo 15, as I recall.
And the reason for showing
it is, first of all,
it is on the lunar surface.
And secondly, the
rover is in sight.
And the last three lunar
modules had the ability
to carry the rover.
They had more oxygen,
more battery power,
and could stay longer.
But let's go back and
see how it started.
The command and service
module got started,
but it was many months later
that the decision was finally
made to embrace lunar
orbit rendezvous.
This was something that
John Houbolt promoted.
And looking back at
it, I don't think
we would have gotten there
without that concept.
So that was finally embraced,
I think, in July of '62.
And then there
was a competition.
And it was an
interesting competition.
The center in Houston
asked 20 questions.
And you had to answer
those 20 questions
in not over 100 pages, and with
print not below a certain size.
And the idea was that if you
knew what you were doing,
it would show in the
answers to those questions.
Well, we did submit a proposal.
I'm not sure that our
then-senior management
expected that we would
ever win anything.
But we had to have a
strong design in order
to answer the questions.
And this is what
we had at the time.
Now, this was a
vehicle that was going
to be considerably lighter than
what eventually came out of it.
And it had,
interestingly enough,
five landing legs on the
premise that if you broke one,
it wouldn't tip over.
The other thing that's
interesting about this
is that there were
two docking hatches.
And we had reason to believe
that that was an advantage.
We had a helicopter-like cabin.
That didn't last long, but
the idea of good visibility
was there.
And I'll show you.
And this shows that there's
an aft equipment bay.
Well, we did have an
aft equipment bay.
It didn't quite look like that.
And then we'll jump right
away to what finally came out.
And this was taken
from Apollo 9,
the flight test in Earth orbit.
And it's really upside
down, but it's easier
to understand this way.
And here, you can see the
probes on the landing gear.
There's great concern that the
dust on the surface of the moon
would obscure
things to the point
where you needed some mechanical
indication of landing.
This also shows the exhaust
[? valve ?] of the descent
engine, and the rather
massive insulation around it.
Up at the top is the
rendezvous radar.
There was a flasher
here, which was
a backup means of rendezvous.
And in this picture, you really
can't see the two windows,
because what we have done
in developing the cockpit
arrangement was to turn the
front of the vehicle inside out
and pull the windows right
back to the astronaut's eye.
Now, we hadn't been into this
contract for more than three
months when we began
to understand what
some of the priorities were.
Now, this was a "cost plus
incentive fee" contract.
And the incentives
depended on performance--
which turned out to
be largely weight--
schedule, and cost.
Well, I think in
about three months,
it came to us that those
things were not equal.
Performance was
clearly number one.
We do our best to
meet the schedule.
And I hate to say this,
Joe, but we really
left the cost to come
third, as he well knows.
But that was an important idea.
And it took us about two years
to firm up the final design,
because at the time we
were in the competition,
we did not know, for
example, the details
of the MIT-designed
guidance system.
And then, of course,
there were requirements
like a backup guidance
system and so on.
Let's go on.
I'm not sure which
mission this came from,
but this was the ascent stage.
And I picked this
slide particularly
to show the rendezvous
radar, the front door--
the front docking
hatch that we proposed
became a door, not
a docking hatch.
And then this was the
ascent engine exhaust here.
And this gives you
a pretty good idea
of where the propellant tanks
for the ascent engine were.
It also shows clearly the quad
reaction control thrusters.
There were four on each of the
four corners of the vehicle.
It's also pretty
clear that this is not
a very aerodynamic vehicle.
To a group of
airplane designers,
this was a real
awakening, that we did not
have to worry about
conventional aerodynamics.
And it became very
utilitarian in appearance,
and only its designers
could love it.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
GAVIN: Now, at the
time that we started,
not much was known
about the lunar surface.
In fact, there was a well-known
astrophysicist from Cornell
who said, look,
there's going to be
10 meters of impalpable
dust, and not only will you
sink into it, but
electrostatically, it's
going to swarm right
up over the vehicle.
Well, I think he told me
that in 1965, by which time
we were reasonably
committed to the design,
and we didn't buy it.
And fortunately, he was wrong.
But we did have a pretty
conservative approach
to landing, as you can see by
reading some of these things.
And vertical 10 feet per
second is a pretty good jolt.
Now, if you land on
an aircraft carrier,
you worry about maybe
20 feet per second.
But for a land-based airplane,
that's not too unreasonable.
But since we didn't
know about the surface,
we made some very
broad assumptions.
We assumed everything
from landing
on the equivalent
of ice to landing
in four small craters
ideally located
to trap all four landing gears.
And we landed with
various pitching motions,
rolling motions, yawing
motions, uphill, downhill.
And 400 runs later, we
thought we had conservatively
surrounded this problem.
And as it turned out much later,
we probably had over-designed.
Now, one of the things
that occurred to us--
not at the very beginning,
but into it a few months--
was that this vehicle only
has to make one landing.
Now, that's a revelation
too to somebody
who's been designing airplanes.
And so we decided that--
oh, well, this is the
tip-over condition
that we worried about.
So the shock-absorbing
material is aluminum honeycomb
in a billet.
And it's good for one landing.
It will take the shock
and eat up the energy.
It does not rebound, and you
can't use it a second time,
but of course, we're not
using it a second time.
Now, we-- in conventional
aircraft fashion--
ran some drop tests as soon
as we had a vehicle to drop.
And we hoisted up in the hangar
and got all the conditions
just right, and let it go.
And it came down
with a crash that
was absolutely
frightening, because all
of the gauges in this machine
were much lighter than anything
we had experienced in aircraft.
And I'm going to say a
little bit about that later.
But it made a terrible noise.
And it made us so
worried at a later date
about the flexibility
that, much later, we
insisted on a drop
test where we had
all of the wiring and
electronics in the vehicle
to see whether the
flexibility of the vehicle
would interfere with
the electrical systems.
Actually, we didn't find any
electrical system problems,
but we did find one
small mechanical problem
that we had to fix.
Now, I'll add a few more
points about the landing gear.
We provided the ability
to absorb something
like 30 inches of [? travel ?]
in the landing gear.
I don't think any of
the actual landings used
more than 3 inches.
And by the time we
got to this point
[? that ?] we knew a little bit
more about the lunar surface,
the astronauts had
spent a lot of time
in the simulator figuring
out how to fly it.
And what they really
wound up doing
was to set a known rate of
descent on the autopilot,
and then fly the machine
manually in the other planes.
And that worked very well.
And I think, as a conclusion,
we can say the landing gear was
somewhat over-designed.
But this also shows
one other thing.
It shows that there's ample
clearance between the descent
rocket engine exhaust
bell and the surface.
And this became
critical later when
we added the lunar rover and the
extended stay time provisions,
because we then had
a heavier vehicle.
And in order to get there with
the same amount of propellant,
we had to extend this
bell a few inches.
And it turned out that that
would work, and was acceptable,
and that's what we did.
Now, the other thing that
came out of these landings
is that, unlike what
happens on the ground,
on Earth here, when a vertical
landing machine comes down,
you have dust that
starts out sideways,
and then pretty soon, you
have billows coming up
because of the interaction
with the atmosphere.
Well, on the moon,
there is no atmosphere.
And what seems to happen
is that the dust takes off
horizontally, and just
goes out of the picture,
so that the dust that
we worried about earlier
wasn't that much of a problem.
Now, one of our worst problems--
it was with us every
day for 10 years--
was the tendency of
the vehicle to grow.
And I think the
significant point
is from about here, when
the design was finally
pretty much finalized.
And then we had
the weight growth.
And then we had a huge effort--
huge in numbers of man hours--
to squeeze the weight out of it.
And then over here in early
'67 was the fire at the Cape,
and that led to some tests
with an iron monster cabin
and a variety of other things
to ensure that fire would not
occur inside the reduced
pressure of a pure oxygen
atmosphere in the cabin.
And so the weight
went back up again.
And then, of course, this
represents the addition
of the rover and the longer
stay time provisions.
To give you some idea of what
the fireproofing amounted to,
this is the back of a
circuit breaker panel.
And we have little baggies--
well, we found, of course,
that the circuit breaker
housings themselves would burn.
So then, what to do?
So we created these
little baggies
that went around that
circuit breaker body.
And then all of the other
electrical connections
were covered with this
mud-like material.
I thought I'd never forget
its name, but I have.
And it was a very
extensive redesign,
and I would say that we lost
about a year at that point.
To continue with
the weight story,
this is a picture of the ascent
stage tanks that are spherical.
They're very thin.
Proportionally, they're
thinner than egg shells.
And they were designed on the
basis of fracture mechanics
to be good for no more
than 100 pressurizations.
The propellants were fed
to the engines by pressure.
The pressure was helium.
And so every tank
had a pedigree.
Every test that was
made was recorded.
And we made sure that before
it went off on a mission,
that there were an ample
number of cycles left.
And this is a view of
the descent stage tank.
And this is
similarly thin stuff.
In fact, we did a lot of our
testing with referee fluids--
in other words, fluids that
had the characteristics
of the nitrogen
tetraoxide and the UDNH,
but which were not
nasty to handle.
And we did a lot of the
testing with heavyweight tanks.
When we received our first
lightweight descent stage
tank, of course, we filled it.
Checked the volume.
And consternation set in
because it held 20 seconds more
propellant than
we had counted on.
And so then the question was,
did somebody make a mistake?
Well, no, they hadn't.
What happened was that under
the weight of the propellant,
the tank stretched.
And we were very happy to have
that extra 20 seconds' worth,
because if you remember
Armstrong's first landing,
he hesitated a bit to
clear some boulders that he
was coming in on.
And I think he was down
to about 20 seconds
at the time he touched down.
The rest [? of ?]
mission control
were blue at that point.
And while we're
talking about tanks,
I'll talk a little bit about
one of our other very major
problems, which crept
up on us so slowly
that we didn't realize how
bad it was going to be.
But we had leaks.
Now, nitrogen tetraoxide
is a nasty material.
If it finds a small
leak, the small leak
soon gets to be a bigger leak.
And it's toxic, so you
really don't want a leak.
And we had designed everything
so light and slender
that we had leaks
around these ports
at the bottom of the--
particularly the descent stage
tanks.
And we worked hard at this.
In fact, we wound up
changing all the seals.
And in fact, one of the vehicles
that was already at the Cape
had to send back this
whole lower structure
so that we could redo the seals.
It was a terribly
frustrating affair.
And we were looking
for leaks that
were on the order of 1
cubic centimeter per year.
Pretty small leak.
With jet fuel, you would
never worry about that.
Well, then this is a picture in
our final assembly area, where
we have an accent stage that's
being supported independently
of the descent stage.
And it shows you some of the
precautions we took with some
of the thinner gauge materials.
And some of these
structural gauges--
say, in this shear web--
were really quite thin.
We got down to ten thousandths.
We would chem mill
down to ten thousandths
and keep the extra
thickness around the edges
where the connectors were.
And we tried going to 008.
And then we counted the number
of grains across a 008 section
and chickened out.
We went to the ten thousandths.
I might add that we
chem milled almost
everything you can think of.
Propellant tubing
was chem milled,
keeping the original thickness
where the connectors were.
And I can't offhand say how
many man hours were expended
in trying to save weight,
but it was a large number,
and it was an endless process.
Now, this is a picture of
the ascent stage in sort
of a stripped condition.
Can see the ascent
propellant tank.
You can see its
support out here.
This is a good picture of the
window, which is just inches
from the astronaut's eye.
And you can also
see that we have
the separate tanks for the
reaction control system.
And that was one system that
was completely redundant.
We had a set of tanks on
either side of the machine.
And these tanks were
positive expulsion.
In other words, there
was a bladder in them
that allowed the
pressure to surely
drive the propellant out.
And of course, we used the
reaction control system
not only for maneuvering,
but to settle
the propellant in the main tanks
before a main engine firing.
Now, this was the next step
in the assembly of the asset
stage.
And for those of you who
are familiar with airplanes,
this is an inside-out machine.
In other words, in an airplane,
you get the sleek exterior,
and then you package
everything inside it as densely
as you can, as
some people say, so
that even if you dropped
a broken egg into it,
it wouldn't drain through.
But here, we had a
machine that didn't
have to be
aerodynamically slick,
so we built it inside-out.
Much of the wiring--
much of the equipment were
outside the pressure vessel.
And you can see some
of the wiring here.
And then, on the
outside, we're going
to have a thermal shield
which also doubled
as a micro meteoroid bumper.
And that had to be
supported somehow.
And that led to this
birdcage-like affair,
which supported this skin.
Now, this-- you might ask, well,
how come some parts are shiny
and some parts are black?
Well, let me just say that a
very extensive thermal analysis
was done, because we
were trying to minimize
the power necessary
in this vehicle
to cut down the amount
of batteries that
had to be carried, and also
to cut down the amount of heat
that had to be put overboard.
And this is the result
of some tests and both--
well, analysis as well as tests
in a thermal vacuum chamber.
This is a better view of the
reaction control thruster.
You see, there are four--
a similar [? quad ?] on
each corner of the vehicle.
One of the things that was
added very late in the game--
and which is not
on my model here--
is this shield which
protects the descent stage
from the firing of
the reaction control
thruster that's pointing down.
This was the result
of some tests
fairly late in the program
that were done on the reaction
control thrusters at the
manned spaceflight center.
This is another view of
the final assembly area.
This is an ascent stage that
is substantially complete
at the front end,
but hasn't been all
put together on the back end.
And the reason for showing
this is to show you
that the equipment--
batteries, radios-- were
mounted on coal rails.
The coal rails had glycol
circulating in them.
The glycol heated water.
The water went overboard
through a porous plate
so that, in effect,
ice was formed,
and it sublimed into space.
And that was the only
way we could get heat out
of the vehicle if we
had too much heat.
This also shows some
of the paperwork.
The weight of the vehicle--
I'm not sure whether it weighed
more than the paper or not,
but we had extensive
pedigrees on just about
everything you can think of.
And that's a very
important thing,
because way back
in the beginning,
we worried about reliability.
At that time,
aircraft experience
was not particularly attractive.
It didn't give you
any great assurance.
And one of our people
came up with the idea
that there should be no such
thing as a random failure.
If you have something
that doesn't work,
either a ground
test or any test,
you ought to be able to find
out what it is and fix it.
And in the course
of 10 years, we
had something over 14,000
such anomaly reports,
and I believe only 22 escaped
satisfactory analysis.
In the case of those 22, we
changed something anyhow.
And I think it
was this attention
to the nasty little details
that made a difference.
I've mentioned tests.
I should point out
that we couldn't flight
test this vehicle.
It's made only to fly in space.
We couldn't hot fire it
because our experience
with the propellants
was that you really
couldn't clean the system
adequately if you used it.
In other words, the
propellers would tend to gum
up the solenoid
valves and so forth.
So each vehicle that was
launched from Cape Kennedy
was an unused, untested
vehicle in every sense
except electrically.
We were able to do a
rather thorough job
in electrical checkout.
But it did lead to the process
of setting up a very complex--
and I should tell you--
steadily evolving
ground test system
so that we could
assure ourselves
that the equipment
we were getting
was good, that it would work
after it was in the vehicle,
and so on and so forth.
This is a photo from
the final assembly area
again, showing a complete
vehicle except for the landing
gear here.
And same thing here.
And the point here
is simply that we
were working toward a
three-month on-center launch
schedule.
So we had to have these vehicles
coming along fairly regularly.
This photograph
shows a descent stage
after the landing gear is on.
The principal reason
for showing this
is that we had a rather
elaborate blanket of insulation
there to protect the descent
stage when the ascent
stage took off.
We tried to run some tests
in the vacuum chambers
that NASA had at White Sands.
And we could run short bursts at
different levels of separation,
but we had no way of running
a truly dynamic test.
And in fact, we
never really knew
what happened until the
very last mission, when
the TV camera on the rover
was aimed at the takeoff.
And while this is a
still, a lot of stuff
went flying out sideways
from that insulation blanket.
But the vehicle just pops up.
Ascent stage pops up.
Now, I should point
out that we have
a fly-by-wire vertical takeoff
and vertical landing machine.
In the landing condition,
it's like a transport
because it's heavy.
And when it gets back to
dock with the command module,
it's like a [? fighter, ?]
because it's
gone through a 10-to-1
reduction in weight.
I've mentioned people
earlier in what I've said,
but it's impossible to do
credit to all the people
who were involved.
Or for that matter, all the
families that were involved.
We worked a lot of
people very, very hard.
And this is the check-out
group at the Cape.
And I'll read this for you.
This is for the last mission.
"This may be our last,
but it will be our best."
And by that, they meant
fewer anomalies to clean up.
And of course, the
lunar module did work.
And I think that I'd like
to use the view graph now
for a minute.
We could turn off the
slides, and talk a little bit
about something that I
fell into by accident--
namely, management.
This is a program
organization chart,
something that our
customer really wanted.
They wanted to know
who was doing what.
And we put this together.
Now, the trouble with this is
that this is a static chart.
It suggests that all of the
people at one level are equal.
And I've sometimes thought that
an organization chart should
look like a slowly-swirling
galaxy of stars--
some that are brightening
and some that are dimming--
because the roles tend to
change as time goes by.
The other thing is
that I would point out
is that these people
never admitted that they
were on the third level.
Grumman had, I think,
a peculiar culture--
certainly in the time
that I was there--
in that everybody looked at
the company as "my company,"
and they were not adverse
to calling anybody up
to tell them what should
be done differently,
or what was going on.
And it led to a certain
amount of confusion sometimes,
but the word got
around very quickly.
And I will say that,
for many years,
the company never had
an organization chart.
Roy Grumman, who founded the
company, was [? against ?] it,
so we didn't have
it for many years.
The other thing that
I would point out here
is how the manpower
was expended.
And there are a couple of
interesting points here.
We were always under criticism
for running too much overtime.
But it's much more effective--
in my view-- to run overtime
than to try to add people,
in certain cases.
The other thing we ran
into was that these slopes
right in here, I think,
were maximum achievable.
You can bring people on board
a major program just so fast.
Otherwise, you wind up with
people not being productive.
In fact, a good argument,
what happens in major programs
frequently is that the end
date-- or in this case,
the lunar landing date--
was fixed.
And there's a tendency for
the start date to creep.
And of course, the
effort is to build up
as fast as you can in
order to get the job done.
This slope right about here
is 1,750 people per year.
Now, that's an
instantaneous number.
But at the real
peak, we're adding
about 3,000 people a year.
And that comes about
because there's
an acceleration involved.
And by the time we
got here into '65,
we thought we knew
what we were doing,
and could bring people onboard.
And this is particularly
true in bringing
subcontractors onboard.
About half of the effort
went to major subcontractors,
and some smaller subcontractors.
This gap right here
represents the effort
to fireproof everything
that came after the fire
at the Cape.
And then you see we resumed.
What happens here, of course,
is that there are some things
that you can stop, and
there are other things that
just have to keep going.
So you can't really just
come way down here somewhere.
And then, of course,
once you have
reached an operational
stage, things
go downhill pretty rapidly.
Well, I'd like to think a
couple of summary remarks.
We had the advantage of
a long-term commitment.
There are not many
programs that have
had that kind of advantage.
And I give Mr.
Kennedy great credit
for having the gumption
to stand up and say,
"before this decade
is out," and so forth.
I think it was important that
we recognized our priorities.
And in a highly-technical
undertaking,
I think there's no question
in my mind that [? what ?]
you have to do the job right.
If you take shortcuts,
you pay more--
you pay a larger penalty later.
I mentioned the idea of no
such thing as a random failure.
It worked for us.
Some of our people likened
it to turning every stone
on the beach over to
see what was under it.
It felt that way at times.
We invested a tremendous
amount of effort on the ground
simply because we
couldn't flight test.
And some of those ideas
went over into our aircraft
experience later on.
We found we could save time and
effort in developing aircraft
if we did more
work on the ground
and didn't try to fly at
the earliest possible date.
It also taught us what I call
the basic program dilemma.
And that is that if you're
going to do something truly
innovative, you can't possibly
know what the schedule is
and what the cost
is going to be.
And if, conversely, you know
precisely what the schedule is,
and what the cost is, you
ought to stop and think
whether it's worth doing,
because it may be obsolete
before you start.
Now, this is something
that I think engineers
understand quite well.
I've had a terrible time
with some congressmen
on that subject.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
GAVIN: The other
thing I would mention
is that in being in
Europe and in Japan--
and more recently, in China--
the impact of Apollo
has been greater
overseas than it has
been in this country.
The American public is pretty
blasé about these things.
It's assumed that the rocket
scientists can do anything.
Well, they almost can.
But the American public
passes on to something else.
But we created a
reputation overseas
that people are still
trying to catch up with.
And I think this
is something that--
particularly those of you who
are students should understand.
That the Apollo program was
a tremendous sales effort
for American technology.
And finally, last comment.
A lot of people talk
about systems engineering.
It means a lot of things
to a lot of people.
In some cases, it's
just a matter of,
do you get all the interface
signals correct, and so on.
But I think that anybody who's
associated with designing
flying machines--
whether they're flying
in the atmosphere, or in
orbit, or outer space--
really is faced with doing
a superior job of systems
engineering.
And the reason is that if
you don't do a superior job,
the results are catastrophic,
and wind up on page one.
And you really can't
afford to have that happen.
I grew up as an
engineer in a company
that was founded by a pilot,
and [? so ?] some years
were some very senior
pilots in the management.
In the airplane
days, it was simply
"bring the pilot back
one way or another."
And we did that.
And I think that if you have
that in mind when you're
involved with designing
flying machines,
that you will do a superior
job of systems engineering.
Now, sometimes,
you wonder, well,
can you apply that
to other effort?
Well, in a selective
way, you can.
Those little US Postal Service
trucks you see running around
are the result of applying
some of the lessons that
came out of this program.
And that's a whole 'nother
story, so I'll stop there,
and I'll be happy to
take any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you get to the
end of a project like this,
I think you often learn
a lot along the way,
and sometimes think you
could have done something
differently.
Was there anything
you learned at the end
that you wish you
knew at the beginning,
and you would've done anything
differently because of that?
GAVIN: Well, I can
certainly tell you
that if I were doing
it today, there are
some things I'd do differently.
At the time that we
designed the lunar module,
we were very
restricted on where we
could use solid-state devices.
In fact, all of the
communication gear
was made up of
discrete elements.
And I would
certainly avoid that.
That was a nightmare,
getting enough units
that would pass test.
I would also have
a digital data bus,
just to reduce the miles and
miles of wire that we had.
We deliberately went to
a skinnier gauge of wire
than is commonly used
in aircraft in order
to save weight.
And we paid for it, because
we had ever so many faults
that came about from just plain
handling the bundles of wire.
So anything you
could do to get rid
of the old-fashioned way of
wiring would be an advantage.
I think that it's
also quite likely
that a lot of the equipment
that we had-- well, supposing we
take the MIT-designed guidance
and navigation equipment.
I think that can all be done
in a miniaturized version today
that would weigh a lot less.
I'm not sure we'd have
GPS in lunar orbit,
but I'm sure that
what we had, while it
was great for its
time, is something
we could do much better today.
And that's probably true
of almost all equipment.
Larry?
AUDIENCE: Were you
made aware of any
of the parallel developments
in the [INAUDIBLE] Russia,
the [INAUDIBLE] LM?
GAVIN: Not a word.
No, I knew nothing about it.
And I think I can safely
speak for the rest of the crew
that we knew nothing about it.
AUDIENCE: If I could have--
[? and ?] another question.
The success of the LM,
among other things,
was the watershed in
flight simulation.
Does it work the
first time it was
used in its environment
based entirely
upon simulated training?
Can you tell us a little
bit about how that worked,
and how you had
confidence that this
could [INAUDIBLE] first time?
GAVIN: Well, you have to
recognize that 40 years ago, I
was a lot bolder
than I am today.
And so were we all.
But there were some lessons
learned in simulation.
In fact, when we built the
X-29A, the little airplane that
had the forward short wings and
the huge negative stability,
we treated that
in simulation much
as we did the lunar module.
And the pilot came back from
the first flight and said, gee,
it flies just like
the simulator.
So there were some
lessons learned
during the lunar module.
I crashed one of the
simulators several times
for a very simple reason.
If you try to translate along
the surface of the moon,
there's no air resistance.
So in order to stop, you had to
fire in the opposite direction.
You don't automatically
slow down.
Now, that's a thing that is
so counter-intuitive that it
takes training to do well.
Yes, Bob.
AUDIENCE: Joe, you were dealing
with a lot of different people
within Grumman and within NASA.
First of all, how did
you spend your time?
Who did you work with the
most, and what kind of problems
did you get into from a
management [? stance? ?]
GAVIN: Well, I'll answer
the last one first.
Every problem you
could possibly imagine.
In the very beginning, there
was a certain resentment among
the dyed-in-the-wool aircraft
people that this strange group
had brought home a contract
that was going to take a lot
of the company's attention,
and people, and reserves.
So there was a matter initially
of getting the right people.
And fortunately, I had
some excellent support
from people you know,
like Grant Hedrick,
and from then-senior management.
And so we did get
the right people.
And of course, we had to manage
quite a number of somewhat
difficult subcontractors.
Joe Shea remembers
some of those days.
He and I had a great debate one
time walking along the street
down at the Cape as to how much
visibility the NASA people were
going to have into
our subcontractors.
And prior policy had been--
in dealing with other
government agencies,
is that we would manage
the subcontractors,
and that was that.
But he won his point, finally,
and we came down to the idea
that NASA would have visibility
as to our relationships
with the
subcontractors, but they
would communicate to
the subcontractors only
through us, since we were
the prime contractor,
and we felt very strongly that
we had the responsibility.
I'm not sure I've answered
that question adequately,
but that gives you some idea.
Yes, Todd.
AUDIENCE: Joe, you talked
about 10 years of nostalgia,
and the nostalgia over 10
years of frenzy and stress.
Can you share with us the memory
or two of a [? horror ?] story?
GAVIN: Well-- oh, Clyde,
before I get to that,
I want to go back to Bob.
There's one thing
I forgot to say,
and that is that I was
very fortunate in having
a cadre of people with whom I
had worked for 10 or 15 years.
So we were pretty well
calibrated one to the other.
And not only in the
engineering and the things,
but I had a number
of good acquaintances
amongst the technicians
and the foremen.
And every day that
I was in Bethpage
and not traveling to Houston or
some other [? garden ?] spot,
I'd make it my business to
walk through the manufacturing
area or the test area and talk
to the people who were busy
there.
And it's amazing what
you can learn just
by taking an hour's walk
and seeing firsthand
what people are doing, and
what problems they're having.
And some of the
problems are simple.
I recall one where the
thermostat on the heating
system was stuck,
and it was too hot.
And apparently, the
foreman had complained.
Nothing had happened.
Well, I made a phone call.
It got fixed.
So the problems range
all over the place.
I'll tell you that
we did occasionally
have to send people home,
because we discovered that some
of them were punching out at
the end of their 10- or 12-hour
shift, and then coming
right back in and working
another few hours.
And we had some people
who actually made
themselves ill in the process.
But everybody knew what
the name of the game was.
And NASA did a great thing in
having the astronauts visit
the plant, oh, I think about
every second to third week.
So it became a question of,
we are building this vehicle
for someone we know,
not for some agency
that is a bunch of
bureaucrats somewhere.
Now, back to Todd.
Well, the low point in some
days was going to Houston
to make a report on how
we were doing and having
to get up there and
say, well, we've
lost another couple of weeks.
And it's not easy, but
that's the way things were.
And we did what we had to.
Speaking of Houston, I
remember one such meeting
where one of the fellows who
was involved in a navigation
guidance group was
suffering from an earache.
And I thought I
had arranged it so
that he wouldn't go on that
trip, but he went anyhow.
And he was under medication.
And he got up to
the podium to talk
about what they were
doing, and he was so
relaxed from the
medication that he created
a sensational impression.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
GAVIN: But he knew what
he was talking about.
He got away with that.
And afterwards, somebody
asked me, what is he on?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
GAVIN: But that was
the kind of spirit
that we had in the group, and
gives you a couple of ideas
of what went on.
Yes, [? Errol? ?]
AUDIENCE: Joe, if
you had to reach back
to your undergraduate
years and think
about what you learned
in MIT, what carried you
through your career?
GAVIN: Well, that's a
hard question to answer,
[? Errol, ?] because
you see, I never
became an expert at anything.
But I do remember very
clearly Professor Joe Newell,
who taught structures, and who
was a very conservative man.
And when he went to
Washington, he took the train.
And that made a
great impression.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
GAVIN: Made a great impression.
Yes, Stan.
AUDIENCE: When you commented
on some of the things that
might have transitioned into
your airplane activities,
can you comment on maybe
the success and failures
of translating the systems
engineering approaches
that you used into
the aircraft business?
GAVIN: Well, the
question-- in case
you didn't hear it
back there-- was,
were you able to translate
some of the systems engineering
aspects of handling the LM back
into the aircraft business?
Well, you have to
realize that we
took what we had learned
in the aircraft business
and used it in the LM.
And then, of course, we
had on-the-job training
because we ran into
so many difficulties.
And it is true that
we did sharpen up
the aircraft business
a bit after we
space cadets took it over.
We instituted formal
pre-flight reviews.
Now, there always had
been some sort of review
prior to flying a new
airplane, but nothing like
what NASA had taught us to do.
So we introduced that.
That stands out in my--
and the simulation.
That and the simulation
are the two big things.
You see, at the time, we were
involved in some aircraft
that were very highly--
well, had a lot of
electronics in them, and where
things like crosstalk
and mutual interference
had really been worked
on very, very hard.
So-- well, we did also
introduce the matter
of certifying the people
who could open a connection.
With all those
prongs in a plug, it
takes real skill to
avoid damaging it.
And that helped.
But I think that some of the
aircraft we were building
at the time were just as
complicated-- in fact,
some of them were more
complicated than the lunar
module.
As I recall, let's
see, the EA-6B
had something like
80 antennas on it.
So that was not all
that easy either.